les avancées technologiques
c'est bien c'est génial mais ça dépend
ce qu'on en fait un exemple parmi tant
d'autres
lesdites fixe les hypers trucage en gros
ça c'est le fait d'utiliser des
logiciels avancées d'intelligence
artificielle pour créer ou encore
modifier une vidéo pour la rendre
mensongères ou trompeuses
la frontière entre la réalité et la
fausseté peut donc être facilement
brouillée c'est ce qu'a tenté de
démontrer le comédien américain john
peel en 2018 dans cette vidéo qui a été
visionnée à plus de 6 millions de
reprises deux bannis de plusieurs sites
web les hyper trucages sont parfois
difficiles à débusquer et ce qui rend ce
encore plus inquiétant c'est le fait que
la technologie belle se raffine et elle
est de plus en plus accessible à tous on
n'a qu'à penser à quelques-unes des
applis qui circulait hier face à pia la
plus récente appli chinoise appelée à
eau qui permet de remplacer le visage
d'un de vos acteurs préférés par votre
propre visage du camp messin suivante
le nigérian no good heart de fans du
sens mais attention avec des
applications comme facebook ou encore
sao ou toute autre application du genre
demeurons vigilants
il ya des risques de vols de données
personnelles ou d'empiètement sur la vie
privée même des trucages disons plus
élaborés peuvent être trompeurs nancy
pelosi l'a appris à ses dépens alors
qu'une allocution de mme pelosi de mai
2019 a été ralentie à 75% de sa vitesse
normale
le résultat n'est pas l'avantagent de
les leaders démocrates
il n'est venu partager à des millions de
reprises le mal est fait et certains
experts estiment que ce cas de trucages
et le canari dans la mine
le signal très clair que les prochaines
élections présidentielles américaines de
2020 pour être la cible de manipulation
du genre tu es et tu t'égares 5h30
il donne